rappelez vous c'était hier le temps des
promesses le glyphosate herbicide
controversé interdit au plus tard fin
2020 si ce qu'avait annoncé emmanuel
macron fin novembre 2017
devançant les réglementations
européennes le président français s'est
engagé publiquement
j'ai demandé au gouvernement de prendre
les dispositions nécessaires pour que
l'utilisation du glyphosate soit
interdite en france
dès que des alternatives auront été
trouvés et au plus tard dans trois ans
cette déclaration venait en réponse au
classement 2015 de cette substance
parmi les cancérigènes probables pour
l'homme par le centre international de
recherche sur le cancer une agence de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
de nombreuses ong s'étaient mobilisés
pour faire interdire la molécule phare
du désherbant roundup de monsanto
huit français sur dix souhaitent ce
bannissement selon un sondage du figaro
en octobre 2017
seulement voilà suivant les pas d'une
chorégraphie souvent pratiqué à l'elysée
dit de la reculade le glyphosate n'est
finalement pas totalement banni
l'assemblée nationale a ainsi rejeté en
2018 les amendements relatifs à
l'inscription de cette interdition 2021
dans la loi en juin 2020 elisabeth borne
à évoquer la fin du glyphosate avant la
présidentielle de 2000 22
et tout cela pour aboutir un dénouement
coups rudes avance le glyphosate sera
interdit et en même temps il sera
autorisé car un rapport publié le 9
octobre par l' agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire lan cesse présente
une évaluation des alternatives non
chimiques au glyphosate
elle précise qu'elle autorisera les
usages de cet herbicide s'il n'existe
aucune solution de remplacement non
chimiques pour les quatre principaux
domaines d'utilisation viticulture
arboriculture fruitière grandes cultures
forêts landes c'est sa liste et les
situations précises dans lesquelles il
n'existe aucune solution alternative non
chimiques à court terme au glyphosate
elle répertorie par exemple les terrains
en pente ou caillouteux impossible à
désherber mécaniquement pour de nombreux
agriculteurs
le glyphosate est difficilement
remplaçable mais pour les défenseurs de
l'environnement les alternatives
existent puisque les producteurs de bio
les utilisent il reste que la ss a tout
de même restreint les yeux
jacques gricole du glyphosate en
plafonnant les volumes et en autorisant
des usages limiter les écologistes déjà
ulcérée de la récente réintroduction des
pesticides tueurs d'abeilles les
néonicotinoïdes uniquement pour la
culture de betteraves en font déjà des
cauchemars